Oh
[Music]
2016 was a pretty great year for good we
have the awesomeness of Deadpool
stranger things a spider man on screen
that's actually funny and fun and sure
2016 had some rough parts dead
celebrities dr. Yvonne the White House
without the fun or cat exploding phones
and having to pretend to light the
Olympics again may 2016 sad and scary
but Deadpool it all gets redeemed by
Deadpool now if we could just disposed
to that guy in the White House as if he
was a chimichanga every single goddamn
party when you're an adult involves
alcohol either you're drunk or realizing
how much you hate all your drunk friends
and then someone comes in and says let's
get this party really started and
another person says y'all ready for this
and then someone else brings in weed or
coke are always both and you do a bunch
of drugs pass out and wake up to
suddenly see your 37 without much to
show for it and that is way less fun
than bumper cars bouncy houses and
chucky cheese
winter is great it's a reset button the
intermission for the clay that you were
dragged in is seen by your parents known
as life it's a time to get your
together before you have to show off
your arms and legs again the worst
places in America are the muggy swamps
and tried deserts that give you no time
to reflect or rethink your shitty life
choices that's why all the weird murders
and Republican victories happen in
Florida you'd think twice about eating
someone's face it was just a bit too
chilly outside